all right from dallas all the way to
seattle where the hope is from russell
wilson's perspective he gets an offer
that he is happy enough with to sign by
next monday that is the supposed
deadline and bob candot of the seattle
times reported over the weekend little
progress has been made in russell wilson
contract talks and look chris we talked
about this a lot last week i don't think
it really changes our analysis of the
situation the bottom line is the nfl is
a deadline driven business the deadline
is a week away
and in no negotiation do you move to
your bottom line position
with time left on the clock because once
you go to your bottom line you're going
to get squeezed off of it if the
seahawks would put their best offer on
the table today russell wilson and his
agent mark rogers would have a week to
keep working on them to get more so i
think the best play here if you're the
seahawks you put your top offer together
your bottom line offer this is what
we'll pay you you put it on the table on
friday knowing that he'll take the
weekend to think about it and decide on
monday what to do so what what price i
don't know that progress needs to be
made we all know what needs to be done
at this point the dollars are easy to
calculate and i think the big sticking
point is he wants a i believe a
percentage of the salary cap moving
forward to protect him against increases
due to new cba new tv deals and the
influx of cash coming from gambling once
he gets that percentage that he you know
is is comfortable with i think the deal
gets done and the question is will he
get it and the question for the seahawks
becomes are you willing to give it to
him wow so you think it will be a
percentage type thing you think he has a
chance to be the first guy that maybe
does this well if i think he won i think
to get him to give up right 30.34
million for 2020
36.4 million for 2021 and 52.4 million
for 2022 which is what his three
franchise tags would be to get him to
give up that opportunity to go kirk
cousins yeah i think you're going to
need to give him that protection because
the world's going to change dramatically
in the next three years once we have a
new cba once there's new tv deals sure
once 30 35 states have legalized
gambling the nfl identifies all the
revenue streams i i think that that's
the only reasonable protection for any
high-end player specifically a franchise
quarter yeah and either way i'm not too
concerned that there was little progress
so over the last week or the weekend
either way hey the point is russell
wilson's put this on everybody's radar
he's put
he's put the pressure on the seattle
seahawks the media knows about this the
seattle seahawks fan base knows about
this and really
anything other than a long-term deal for
russell wilson in the seattle seahawks i
just feel like the seahawks are gonna be
looked at as what the hell are you
thinking you gotta sign this guy so uh
again i don't know if i totally buy like
i said last week the deadline of april
15th he's put it out there i understand
that that's smart it gets the
conversation going but i don't think
seattle is gonna be in some like super
rush here to make sure it gets done yeah
maybe they put out an offer on friday
but again i don't think russell wilson
is going to turn this down if let's just
say it's may 10th and they offer him a
contract to be the highest paid
quarterback in the history of football
he's not going to go whoa guys hold on i
said april 15th i can't accept it so uh
there's urgency but there's not an
urgency is what i'm saying i think
i don't know if you read
profootballtalk.com on sunday but i
credited you for that theory that if the
seahawks show up on may 15 with whatever
it was russell wilson wanted on april 15
would he say no to that he'd have to be
stupid to say no to that i would think
but again thank you for credit but
but here's my here's my take if if he is
only reluctantly engaging in these talks
if he is hell-bent on taking the kirk
cousins approach and pushing it multiple
levels higher because there's got to
look there's got to be some ego involved
here when these truly great quarterbacks
when the best quarterbacks in the nfl
look at what kirk cousins did and all
due respect here's where the insult
comes to kirk cousins for monday morning
you preempted me earlier chris
it's kirk cousins for crying out loud
i'm russell wilson cousins can play this
game and make 128 million over five
years and force his way to the open mark
and get 84 million fully guaranteed on a
three-year deal if he can do that
what can i do i'm going to go find out
and and that's the one that look
and you know hey seahawks you had your
chance i mean that's going to be the
test if they play this game with him and
they wake up on may 15 and realize we
better just give the guy what he wants
will russell wilson and mark rogers say
hey guys you had your chance we only
engaged in these talks because you you
wanted us to we had every intent of
going year to year we wanted to give you
a chance to talk us out of it you failed
to do it we're going year to year now
guys sorry but uh that's the consequence
of not taking it seriously you should
have yeah oh okay well there's risk in
that too so i you know i think russell
wilson would realize that he's been
great we've talked about that about
staying healthy uh all that makes sense
but still i think at the end of the day
the seahawks don't want that to happen i
don't think russell wilson really wants
to play that way either i mean i would
think russell wilson not only wants the
uh long-term security from from a
contract and guaranteed money but he
just doesn't seem like the type of guy
that wants to be dealing with this type
of nonsense on a yearly basis as far as
franchise talk and is it ever going to
get you know is a contract ever going to
get finished how much longer are you
going to be here in seattle you know
that is the type of stuff that we've
talked about before can divide a team
divide a locker room make things
uncomfortable within a building and
really ruin a culture so they better be
careful with that
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports